This is a syringe full of water.
I've closed off this end
so it can’t escape.
And no matter how hard I push...
Nothing really happens.
I can't compress it.
Even if I put this inside
an industrial hydraulic press...
a machine that can push down
with thousands of tons of force...
the volume would only decrease by about 1%.
But what if it was squeezed even harder?
What if this water was subjected
to the extreme pressures
in the Earth's core?
Or inside the Sun?
What would happen to it?
The answer is something really bizarre.
Something physicists are just starting
to understand.
In many ways, this is
really a new field.
We just don't fully know the rules yet.
It's an entirely new regime of matter.
To try and wrap our heads around
these extreme pressures
and the way they warp physics
as we know it.
Let's go on a journey
straight down.
We'll start our trip up here on the surface
at atmospheric pressure.
How much pressure is that exactly?
How does it compare to, say
the pressure of my phone
on my palm?
Well, the phone's weight,
about two Newtons...
is spread out over about
100 square centimeters.
That's how pressure is measured:
A force distributed over an area.
The pressure of the atmosphere
the hundreds of miles of air above me...
pulled down by Earth's gravity
is 500 times stronger.
That's like the pressure my phone
would exert on my palm
if Dwayne “The Rock” Johnson
was balancing on top of it.
But because the air is free
to flow around...
it's also pushing up The Rock
with the same pressure.
Every phone sized patch of my body
is getting pressed
inward by the equivalent of
The Rock's weight.
Of course, all the structures
and fluids within my body
are pressing back
and I'm so used to this equilibrium
that I don't even notice.
Before we leave these familiar conditions
I'm going to grab a few things to take with us.
A gram of hydrogen,
a gram of sodium...
and a kilo of water.
We know exactly how these substances
behave on Earth’s surface.
But what happens when
we start to squeeze?
Just ten meters of seawater adds
another whole atmosphere
worth of pressure.
27 floors down...
we pass the unassisted diving record.
And just a little deeper...
we hit ten atmospheres.
Now we're going deeper than
the deepest scuba dive.
There's a blob of fish.
They look like depressed jello
on the surface
but down here, the pressure
keeps them trim.
One kilometer down,
we reach 100 atmospheres.
The kinds of pressures we got with that
giant hydraulic press.
Sperm whales can dive this deep...
and their hinged rib cages fold inward
so the bones won't snap.
Here, the Titan submersible
was crushed...
and here is the destination
they never reached.
[My Heart Will Go On by Celine Dion
plays briefly]
Somehow we're still passing fish.
And now we've reached the bottom
of the Mariana Trench...
and 1000 atmospheres.
We're now up to the pressure of a phone
with a herd of elephants
balanced on top.
Let's check in on the samples we brought.
Our balloon of hydrogen gas
has shrunk down to the size
of a big marble.
But both our solid sodium and liquid water
haven't changed much.
They're just barely compressed.
Why is that?
Well, the molecules of hydrogen
had plenty of space between them.
Room to shrink.
But the sodium and water were
already tightly packed.
Even the pressure down here can't overcome
the electrostatic repulsion
between molecules.
It's nowhere near strong enough.
But let's keep going.
Every meter of rock
piles on the pressure
nearly three times faster
than water.
The temperature is rising, too.
As we leave the crust, we hit
10,000 atmospheres.
In the mantle, temperatures shoot past
a 1000 degrees Celsius
and some of the rock starts to melt.
This is where many diamonds form.
Carbon is squeezed into a tight crystal.
As we go deeper into 100,000
atmospheres of pressure...
the rock is compressed further,
forced back into its solid form.
Our sodium, meanwhile, has melted...
and our bubble of hydrogen
is liquid too.
Compressed into a little clear globule.
The water is also changing.
It's getting squashed so much,
it's forced to become a solid.
But not the hexagonal crystals
we get on the surface.
Instead, it's a tighter cubic lattice.
Scientists have found
this variation of ice, Ice-VII...
trapped inside diamonds.
As we get close to Earth's core
we pass 1 million atmospheres.
That's the equivalent of an oil tanker
balanced on a phone.
This is the threshold
we're now leaving the world that
physicists fully understand.
This is where the external forces
are about the same
and starting to overwhelm
the internal forces.
The crushing pressure is starting
to overcome
the electromagnetic forces holding
water molecules apart
apart and maintaining their shape.
The behavior that
comes out of being
in these extreme conditions
is pretty bizarre.
How do you study matter
under conditions
that normally only exist
deep inside the earth?
That was the point of creating the
Center for Matter at Atomic Pressures.
We're going to be doing all the
fundamental physics
to be able to understand matter
under these really different
kinds of conditions.
CMAP is headquartered at
the University of Rochester...
and they've got a tool that helps them
create extreme pressures.
The enormous Omega EP laser
which fills this giant room.
This is the facility's schedule.
Scientists from around the world
queue up for months
just for a chance
to blast a tiny sample of matter
with a laser beam.
And how do you feel in the run up to this?
Unbelievably nervous.
You spent a year of planning
and crossing T's and dotting I’s...
just to get to this point.
The shot director gets on the intercom
and he goes—
Five...
four, three...
two, one.
[silence]
Shot 39607
is now complete.
That was it.
During that split second,
a million atmosphere pressures
were momentarily created in the next room...
the same pressures that exist deep within Earth.
How does a beam of light do that?
Let's go through it again.
Just way slower.
The laser beam is born in these machines
down in the basement...
and it's directed through a maze of lenses
and devices that shape
and monitor it.
Bouncing through these
massive tubes...
it's infused with more power until
it's as wide as this opening:
About 45 centimeters across.
Then it races towards the target chamber
which is hidden behind this tangle
of equipment.
This is a visual representation
of the target chamber.
And the target is right at the center of it.
Those are really, like a pinpoint...
on the tip of a pen,
just absurdly small.
The target is a tiny,
inedible sandwich
with a sample of whatever substance
the researchers are interested in
in the middle.
The laser light is focused down
to hit this first layer
which explodes into a
superheated ionized gas.
And that plasma blows off of
the surface like a rocket.
Ahat creates this buildup of pressure
that forms a shockwave.
And that shockwave really quickly travels
through the material.
The last layer acts as a window
allowing the passage of electromagnetic rays
generated during the experiment.
And then surrounding it
you have these spaces
to put different cameras
and other tools that we use
to measure the various things
that we're interested in.
If you look through this porthole...
you can see a couple of these sensors
getting moved into place.
In 2017, researchers put a tiny bit of Ice-VII
sandwiched between two diamonds...
in the target chamber.
As the shockwave passed through it...
pressure in the ice spiked
above 2 million atmospheres
and its atoms rearranged.
Oxygens formed a tight lattice...
while hydrogens were free
to diffuse through it.
It was Ice-XVIII, four times denser
than normal ice...
and able to conduct electricity
almost as well as a metal.
For a few billionth of a second...
the laser had recreated conditions
inside Earth.
Speaking of, let's get back
to our journey.
As our water starts
to turn into Ice-XVIII...
our glob of sodium is undergoing
its own transformation.
Under these pressures, scientists have seen
it turn transparent.
Now, what could account for this?
Well, metals like sodium are shiny
because they have a bunch of
free-flowing electrons
that can absorb and then retransmit light
which we see as a reflection.
What happens when you apply pressure to it
is you're squeezing the electrons
away from their atoms...
and into these localized pockets.
Trapped like that, the electrons can't
interact with light...
and so it just passes through.
We've reached the center of the earth...
but that's not the end because
we can continue into pressures
found inside larger plants.
Tens of thousands of kilometers
below Jupiter's surface...
Physicists think hydrogen will go through
another change
becoming a shiny conductor of electricity.
It's thought that a lot of Jupiter
is made up of this metallic hydrogen.
We think of high energy
density materials
as completely inverting
the periodic table
so your metals become transparent
and your transparent materials
become metals...
and all these gases become solids...
And the universe holds
higher pressures still.
The center of Jupiter sees over
10 million atmospheres
just about the highest pressure
that the Omega laser can create.
And now we're diving into the sun...
where pressures rise over
100 billion atmospheres.
The island of Manhattan balanced on a phone.
We've seen extreme pressures,
overwhelming the forces
that keep molecules apart.
But here within the sun,
they can overcome
the very glue that holds atoms together.
Here, individual hydrogen nuclei
can be used to form helium...
a process that releases energy.
This is nuclear fusion:
The ultimate source of all energy
in our solar system.
The reaction at the center
of every twinkling star.
If we could somehow
recreate this process on Earth
and keep it going...
we would have a near limitless source
of clean, cheap power.
And researchers around
the world
are using giant lasers,
including Omega...
to study this possibility.
This is all a relatively new frontier
of physics.
Scientists still have so many questions
about the rules
about how different elements and substances
act and interact under different conditions...
and how that might influence
the evolution of planets...
and their ability to foster life.
They'll keep chipping away at those unknowns...
one split second experiment at a time.
[Lump of Coal by Adam Cole]
Hold me close...
Squeeze me tight...
Get together/
Up the pressure
Feels so wrong/
but it feels so right...
Break me down/
Then you make me whole...
You want a diamond/
take your time and
keep on tryin/
‘cause I’m just another coal.
I’m just another coal!
[Lump of Coal by Adam Cole fades]